hey everyone this is sarah with
registered nurse RN comm and today i
wanted to make a quick video and show
you how to properly remove your gloves
as a nurse you're going to come into
contact with many many different germs
some germs are worse than others like
for instance as a nurse i have came in
contact with c diff MRSA VRE of one
patient i had one time had c diff and
MRSA and i had to go in the room because
they had a bowel movement how to change
them so on my gloves I had seed if I had
MRSA I had stool I had many different
things so I use this technique to remove
my gloves so I don't contaminate my
scrubs and I don't think it contaminate
my hands or any other things so if you
follow this one technique that I want to
show you you're going to dramatically
decrease your chances of becoming
contaminated our goal is to get our
gloves like this in a bowl everything
inside of the gloves so I'm going to
show you real quick how to do it first
what you'll do
here's your dirty gloves you are going
to grab the end of this cup the cup grab
the cup do not touch your arm so you're
going to grab it and you're going to
pull it completely off and then with the
glove hand you're going to hold the
glove tighten your hand then with this
unclogged hand you're going to carefully
slip it underneath the club the cup and
you're going to just slide it over that
and then we'll up everything that's
dirty and nasty is inside this glove and
then you're going to throw it away and
of course do hand hygiene wash your
hands and you're good to go so there's a
really quick video on how to remove your
gloves properly if you like this video
please subscribe to my channel and feel
free to share it with your friends and
also visit our website register in our
summer Edgecombe for a lot more nursing
school tips on how to succeed as a nurse
thank you so much and have a good day